職業と仕事って何なのかとね
同じと思っていますからね
業だけで生きていられません
生かされてくれません
人間を だから言ったでしょ
業で全部管理するんだと
しかし 生かされてはくれません
業によって管理されている
制御されているだけです
生まれてから死まで生きるという仕事をしなければならないのです
仕事っていうのは生きることなんです
業だけで生きるのは地獄の生命
神々と梵天です うーん
業が尽きたらまた輪廻転生ですね
ちょっとわかりにくいでしょうかね
で 我々をを業が管理しているんですけど
ただそれで話が終わるんです
何もやってくれないんです
いくら大量の善行を持って生まれても
幸福にしてくれないんです
自分が生きてみたら 正しく
その分 はい お金あります
はい どうぞと そんな感じなんです
銀行と同じ 銀行にむっちゃお金あるんだけど
くれないでしょ 自分の預金の範囲ですね
それにも最近ケチつけちゃったりしてて
もうもう戦略上ではダメと言ったりするし
1 日これぐらいしか出せませんよとかも
自分のお金なのに そんな感じで我々はもう大量にお金を銀行に預かっているような感じなんです
業は しかし こちらそれなりの手続きを踏まないと
その日のその日のお金は返してくれません
そこを理解してほしい
生かされてくれません
自分で生きるんです だから
生まれてから我々はしっかりと正しく生きてみると
過去持ってきた業から
いくらでもいくらでも恵みが流れてきます
それで過去の業だけでボケーとしていても生きていられるのは地獄に落ちたからなんです
そんなにも生かされて欲しければ
もう行くところはあります
みんな思ってもね 生かされているんだとか
それから神を信仰する宗教は堂々と言うんです
ありえない 生きているんです
どう見ても人間が生きているんだって
生かされているわけじゃないんです
そんなにも生かされていることありがたければ
地獄はあるでしょうに行ってみれば
そうすると 否応なしにその命をもう頑張らなくちゃ
頑張る必要もないんです
やられるだけだから 天界に生まれると可哀想なところも同じなんです
神々も自動で幸福に楽しくいるんです
何もあえてやる必要はないんです
だから結局自由がないんです
地獄に落ちたことと比較して
地獄に落ちたら苦しみだけ
じゃあこれから地獄に落ちたことだから苦しんでやると誰も思ってないんです
地獄が苦しいんです それで業がある限り
もうそちらにいるんです
首を切っても死ぬわけじゃないんです
別に我々みたいに肉体の首があるわけじゃないし
精神的な体だから首があると思ってるんです
切れちゃうんです すごい痛みを感じるんです
恐ろしい ではまたあるんです
で また切れちゃう またあるんです
切るたびに首を切る苦しみを味わうんですよ
今の我々は肉体は苦しげないんですよ
肉体には痛くも痒くも何でもないんです
この感覚があるんだからな
感覚というのは心なんです
今の我々は心で苦楽を感じているんです
肉体で感じているわけじゃないんです
だからこれは肉体はカットして
精神だけになったらどれほど苦しめるかというと
切りがないんです で 天国に行ったら逆に楽しめるんですね
しかし 自由がなくなっちゃうんです
プログラム通りに動くしかないんです
人間は生かされてないんです
生きているんです 生命
だからありがたいんですよ
で 職業はある一定の時間で収入を得るための働きですよ
職業っていうのは 仕事は別です
仕事は生きることです
仕事は一生しなくてはならないものです
で 職業仕事をしなくて
したくないと思う人も何もしない
怠ける 妄想するという仕事をして幸福になるはずの称号を壊すんです
文章はややこしいんですけど
まあ話と同じですけど
まあ一応簡単に言えばあの
言いますね 仕事はしたくないとかね
いう人々は しかし 仕事をしたくないというのはしなくちゃいけないんですよ
しているんです はっきり言えば仕事をしないでいられないんです
だから仕事をしたくないとか言ってる
この愚かな人々が結局は仕事をしている
怠ける  1 日中  1 日中妄想にふけっている
1 日中親を恨んだり 家の中で喧嘩したり
暴力振るったりやってますよ
ちゃんと仕事を あるいは仕事に行きたくないとか言っても
もうこう 10時半まで 12時まで寝たり
ビデオを見たり テレビを見たりとか
あれって仕事です 仕事をしないでいられるはずもないんです
だから そんな屁理屈はね
なんで世の中であるんですかね
仏教を知らないからなんです
仏教から見れば 魚は泳がないようにいるっていう話と同じなんです
魚はどうやって泳がないでいるんですかね
話にならんでしょう 人間なら仕事をするんです
生まれた時から死ぬまで
それで仕事はしたくないという人も仕事をしているんです
残念ながら その仕事はもう偉大なる幸福で生まれたこの馬鹿どもたちが
もうもうとてつもない不幸になるんですよ
いかに馬鹿かというとね
それはエピソードまで仏教であるんですよ
例えばもう億万長者で生まれて
形になると物を乞うて道歩いているならば
頭いいと言えますかね
どこまで馬鹿かと だから億単位じゃないんですよ
我々の業のパワーが だから仏教はそんなに金に執着するなよと
財産に執着するなよと
自由にいてみなさいよと
それでも何のこともないんです
全く執着しなくても 金がなくなるだけで何でもないんです
すごく幸福に生きる人はもういつでも幸福
だから あれは余計なことは黙っておかなくちゃ
もう握っておかなくちゃとかね
それであの仕事をしたくない
もう会社に行きたくないという人々も仕事をしていますよ
その仕事で あの大量の幸福を全部火をつけているんです
で 仏教の ありましたけど
さっさと言いますけど
このマハーダナ・セッティというのは大金持ちの家がありまして
一人息子が生まれて  180億金貨で稼いで多く財産がありまして
また同じ金持ちの家がありまして
これまた 180億金貨で稼いだ財産があって
また一人息子が それで同じレベルの家族ですから
あの息子にこんな財産があるんだから
この人はいくら使っても死ぬまで使いきれません
このお金はと だから自分の息子が死ぬまでもお金を使うだけであったっても消えます
それぐらい財産があるんだと
ですから 勉強は教えなくてもよろしいと
数学なんか教えなくてもよろしいと
苦しいんだと 数学を教えると暗記しなくちゃいけないんですね
うちの子にはそんなのは苦しいとかね
では絵描きで絵描きすると目がじーっと睨んでなくちゃいけないから
目が悪いね 目に目が痛くなっちゃうんだから
うちの息子はと だから文字数
文字数とは昔指でまず書いてみるんだからね
指が痛くなるんだと うちの子はそんな痛い目に遭わせたくないんだと
何も教えてなかったんです
ただそのまま大人になったんです
娘さんも同じで それで結婚したんです
それで全部財産一緒になっちゃったんです
その財産が何年も経つ前に全部なくなったんです
みんな騙して取っちゃったんです
あの 夫婦 あの嫁が亡くなったら
両家の それで周りの悪人たちがね
あのバカな男がね バカな女と結婚してね 10
までも数えられませんよと
これはチャンスやと言って
もう賭け事に連れて行ったりして
そうするともうわからないでしょうね
賭け事なんかもう10までも数えられない人は
あ 先生ではなくて あ なんて言いますか
ご主人様の負け あ そう
負けって言うんですかねと
そうなんですけど じゃあそれでお金払わなくちゃいけない
この人に 数えられませんから
はい これぐらいでいいんでしょうかと言って
もう金貨をもうちょっとあげた方がいいんだよと
それでもう 1年  2年ぐらいで全部なくなっちゃった
それからもう家も取られて追い出されたんです
あれほど金がある 追い出されたところで
もう何もできんでしょ
だって米ちょっと洗って炊くぐらいも
それもできない で 乞食になったんです
あ それで誰もわからない
この夫婦は誰かと思う
それぐらいになって ある日
お釈迦様の源宗者で まあお坊さんたちが食べて終わったものもたくさん残りますから
全部みんなにもう配りたくて配るんです
それでアンサンジャーが全部食べ物を食事終わってからね
鉢に残ったものはみんなに並んでもらって配ってるんです
それとお釈迦様 そこら辺にアヌンさんが出て
この若手の男と女が座っていて
お坊さんたちは食べ残ったものを食べているんです
アーナンダ この二人知ってますか？知りません
この二人はあの大大億万長者の一人息子と一人娘がおらかさで今こんなことになっているんだと
若い時はちょっと何か学んだならば
頑張ったならば 頑張ったならば
国の一番トップの金持ちになって
王様から勲章をもらうはずでしたと
全部捨てて出家したならば
悟るはずでした それぐらい業があったということなんです
今どちらでもないんだよ
今ということは じゃあ出家してみるそうで言ったらダメなんです
もう終わり  0 業 いかにもったいないかと
だから皆様も自信持ってください
もう億万長者の業じゃないんですよ
持ってるのは だから別に億万長者になってそんなひどい目に遭う必要はないんだけど
穏やかに幸福に生きられることだけは生きられます
四業の業は必ず悪業にするんです
ということで だからこの仕事をしたくないと
家で怠けてる人々は 今世を不幸にするだけじゃなくて
あれは悪業をやってますよ
ですから 来世も知ったことじゃないんです
朝早く起きて 仕事に行って
クタクタ疲れて家に帰って
もうなんとか食べて寝て
また朝早く そういう人々は良いことをやってます
頑張ってるんです 生きているんです
別に派手な良いことをする暇がなくても
今の生き方はまとめですからね
それが善行為なんです
だから仕事をしたくない
あれやこれやという人々はかわいそうですよ
今世だけじゃなくて 来世まで
はい 適職を求めて無駄足
適職に恵まれるなら断言的な楽ですよ
適職の定義しましたからね
過去世で慣れたもの 人は全くの合わない仕事に就かないので心配無用です
このなんで適職探すんですかね
あまりにもヘリクツ 自分に全く合わない仕事には就かないんですよ
そんな不幸じゃないんですよ
人間は なのに なんだこれはと
無駄でしょうに 適職を探すこと自体は
不適な仕事には就かないんです
はい では皆様に聞きます
次のオリンピックに皆様一人代表で選べると思う？お願いする
オリンピック選手を選ぶはなんとか組織あるでしょ
そちらから何々さん 今度はあの
日本は一応目立ってるのはといえばね
スキーのジャンプとかね
高いくつかありますからね
それから女の子のやっているスケートとかね
やっぱりあのちゃんがまだまだ子供だからね
じゃああんたが一人いかがですかね
選べませんよ 適職じゃないんです
あれは シニアゴースト大会には石川遼君が行ってますよ
皆様 いくら踏ん張っても
もしかすると見学するチケットももらわないかも
だからなんだこの無駄足
自分に就いた仕事は自分の適職なんですよ
本当のと正直なとこ 私は
私は本当はこれもう説くのは好きじゃないんです
一番嫌なのは瞑想を教えることなの
いまだに嫌なんです しかし
そればっかりやってるでしょ
それで世界中の他のお坊さんたちやらいろいろ私はちょこちょこ調べてみると
やっぱり適職や これは私ほど上手に誰にもできないなと
知ってます できればやってみてください
誰でもどんな偉い立派な有名な人
叶わないんです ただ 皆様やらないだけのことで結果ないんですけど
それはもう私の責任じゃありません
教えるもんはもう世界一流で教えてるはずなんです
なんでも で 私は言うこと
私は注釈書はいろんなところ調べてみますよ
全くぴったしで まあ時々私の解説はブッダがちょうどにもできない
だからまあしかし あれ好きでやっているわけじゃないんですよ
なんとなくもう流れてしまっちゃったんです
なんとなくそうなる みんな聞くんで
日本に来ても何の目的もなかったんです
笑い なんで仏教を教えることに全然思ってもなかったんです
なんとなくそうなってしまっただけなんです
悪運命の流れで しかし
見てみると適職です こんな自分にとってはよく仕事をしましたっていう充実感
他何やったっても出てこないんですね
他のことをいろんなことをやってみますけど
すべて中途半端 だから誰でも自ら適職に就くんですよ
失敗するのはあなた方のせいなんです
こう無駄足です 適職探すの
たとえそのようなことがあっても
たちまち辞めますよ  ６０歳のおばあちゃんに突然あのもう４００メートルっていうんですか
あのありますね 競争だ
走ってくださいって おばあちゃん
ああ じゃあそこまで言うならばやってみますと言ったって
ちょっと走ってやめますよ
いいよ 結構やと だから合わない仕事はすぐ誰でも辞めます
私は知ってる日本の人なんですけど
すごく能力がありまして
まあいくつかの会社に仕事に面接に行って
かなり給料良い会社がありましたんですけど
会社もやっぱりあなたならね
こちらからお願いして雇いたいくらいですよ
しかし あなたにはこれ適職じゃないでしょうと
理由はまあ まあ原子力関係の仕事です
この人はそういう人類に危険なことはやりたくないという
まあ道徳的にできているんですね
読めるんですよ 仏教ひとかけらも知らない人々も
あなたはいくら能力才能あっても
こういう仕事をすると苦しくなるでしょうと
本人もまあ そういうことで
別に本当に立派な別な仕事を任されたんですね
それは結構才能が必要な必要をする仕事ですけど
まあ人類幸福になる仕事ではなくて
幸福になる仕事だから元気で頑張ってはいいので
だから聞いたところで
私はもう珍しいではなくて
まぁ無実なものかな 無実なものだなと
人生っていうのは 何のことなく適職に就くんですよ
やりたくない できないという怠けと無知な感情で悩んでも
適職ではないと言えるものではありません
ただやりたくない怠け
それだけ だから私は軽々説法するんだからって
全然苦しくも何ともないわけじゃないんですよ
結構大変ですよ もう もうこういう経典も引用しないで
何もしないで喋るってことは大変です
だって他の人だったら随分勝手に喋りますけど
我々は一応この伝統の人々でしょ
責任持たなくちゃいけないんですよ
ブッダの言葉にはもう微塵も逆らったらあかんで
あらゆる束縛 条件があるんですよ
だから一番楽な方はどこか経典から引用して
こういうふうに教えまったらはい
さようなら しかし 現代人にそれが通じるかないかはまた別でしょうに
だからまあかなり苦しいんですよ
時々ガタンと倒れるぐらいもう疲れます
終わったら だから楽々じゃないんだけど
もう別にこれ怠けです
やりたくない やりたくくないと
適職は苦しくてもやるしかないんですよ
だから適職探すということは
ただの怠けなんです 職業を選ぶとき
次選ぶ問題 無知で欲と怒りで見栄で判断しない程度で十分です
軽々と選んでくださいってことなんで
無知で選んではいけません
あまりにも欲でとにかく儲かってやれそうとかね
あるいはアイスよりとにかく良い会社にとにかく入ってる
これは怒りですね あるいは見栄で
選ぶ必要はないんです
とにかくトヨタ会社に入ってみるぞとかね
ソニーエンターテイメントに入ってみるぞとか
世界的な大会社だから
で 結局クビになるところはどんな会社でもクビになりますしね
そうではなくて まあちょっとした家具を作る会社であってもいいかもしれませんよ
まあとにかくこのその程度で仕事内容を見て
あ これならできますといいんです
この会社はやっぱりかっこ悪いとかね
社長はジジイですからね
いつでもブル服作業服ばっかり着てる
格好はネクタイもつけないんです
そんなことで判断すると大変なことになります
だから仕事を選ぶ場合は簡単ですよ
欲で怒りで見栄で選ばなくて
仕事の内容を見たら これならできそうな
じゃあやる それで話は終わりますよ
仕事の選択できる贅沢な時期では
やりたい仕事ではなくて
やりやすい 簡単 失敗なくできる仕事を選ぶんです
今 贅沢な時期じゃないんだけど
あの どんな仕事にしようかなとかね
思う時期もあったんだから
日本ではね 大学生はね
もうたくさんいろんな就職のいろんな本をたくさん持って
もう調べるわしだ こちらかこちらですよ
こちら それで会社の方もなんかすごく誘惑するんですよ
セミナーやったり 会社に呼んでいろいろご馳走を食べさせて
講演やったり 会社のでっかさを見せたりとか
人材獲得のために 今逆でしょうに
だから この贅沢の時期でどうすればいいかというと
その時も気をつけてやりやすい仕事を選ぶ
失敗しにくい仕事を選ぶ
自分から見れば自分に簡単という仕事を選ぶんです
それが適職なんです 不景気な時は贅沢は言わない
言えない 今はそんな贅沢を言えるところじゃないんです
人は簡単に仕事に慣れるものです
それはまた後です だから今の時期だったら
全くの贅沢は言わないこと
万が一あなたにこれできる
こんな仕事あるんですけど
はいはい やります やります
と飛んで行った方がいいんです
これもうできるかできないか考える必要ないんです
今はとにかく仕事だけやればいいやと思わなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると難しかったらどうしよう
大丈夫ですよ どんなものも心っていうのは簡単に慣れます
すぐ慣れます そんな大げさなことじゃないんです
才能と性格 適職にのみしがみつくのは怠けではないでしょうか
だから適職 適職 これは怠けです
1 慣れた仕事だけやりたい人もいるし
2 やったことがない仕事もやってみたいという人もいるのです
人間 2種類 やっぱりよく慣れているできる仕事にしますか
やっぱりやったことないんだから
あんな仕事って一度やってみたいなという人もいますよ
2種類 失敗したくないという慈しみであれば
1 もよし 成長したいなら 2 もよしです
どうでもいいんです そんなに
しかし 上限があるんです
仕事だから失敗してはいけません
人間に迷惑をかけてはいけません
だから私は慣れている仕事に決めると
それはいいことですよ
やっぱり能力っていうのは簡単に
もう上がっちゃいますから
挑戦してみますという 2番目はいいんです
それが性格です で 型のない心
心に型がないんです 習うにも慣れるにも心です
心なら何でもやりたい
何でも知りたいという限りのない希望で
我々の心っていうのは限りのない希望ですよ
何でもやりたがるんです
何でも知りたがるんです
みんなそういう心を持ってますよ
これが欲望だけで表わしているのはまずいんですけど
欲だったら切りがないんだと
それだけじゃないんですよ
それは失敗している人々なんですよ
我々の心っていうのは何でも知りたがるんですよ
この年になって 私は何か新しい外国語でも学ぼうかなと思ったりもしますよ
一回インターネットで調べたんですけど
なかなかうまく選択できなかったんですよ
だからまた今なら何のためやと思って
まあそんなに追求しなかったんですけど
やっぱり心っていうのは
やっぱり何でも知りたいんですよ
役に立つか立たないは関係ないんです
ただ知りたいだけ だから皆さんそうでしょうし
知りたいものはいくらでも知りたいと思ってるし
やりたいものでも何でもやりたがるし
それが心の性格なんです
これできるのは心には形がないんですよ
だからなんです しかし
心は本来無知なので 現実は何もでき
現実は何もできないという状態です
だから何でも知りたがるのは悪くないんですよ
問題は心は無知なんですね
だから欲望はあるんだけど
現実的にはできないんです
つまり実現することはできないんです
皆様も英語をペラペラ喋りたいでしょ？できればフランス語もペラペラ喋りたいでしょ
実はどちらでもできません
ということでしょ 現実は
だからあの その差があの心の無知だから起こるんです
理性があればできないとは成り立ちません
ですから 覚えておいてください
心に理性があれば このできないということはなくなるんです
やればできる やればできるというみんなもうよく謳ってますけど
あれは何もわかってないでいるんですよ
理性が必要なんです 無知がダメなんです
理性が入ると何でもできるようになります
その必要はあるか否かでリミットをつかないと大変です
だから心は何でも知りたがるんだけど
たとえ理性があっても気をつけた方がいいんです
もし私がもう今更何か外国語を学ぼうと思ったら
日本でもいろいろ教室ありますけど
行ったらどうなるんですかね
これ ちゃんと定期的に通わなくちゃいけないでしょ
それで全部パンになっちゃいますよ
もう金曜日授業やりますから
何時までですから だったら毎日そこで束縛されるでしょう
週 3 日間行かなくちゃとかね
こうすると 私の今の仕事は成り立たなくなりますね
それでフランス語を学んだんだからといって
まあ日常会話程度で何の役にも立ちませんしね
だからやりたいこと気持ちはあるんだけど
やればできますよ 皆様
お金でもかけるならば競争してやりましょうか
皆様より見事にすごい目の速さ
速さで喋ってみせます
そういうからくりは知ってますよ
しかし 必要か否かでいえば必要ではありません
だから私は見事にリミットをつけています
だから人生そういうふうに管理するんですよ
何でも知りたいが 必要なものを知ることにすると
仕事と道徳の話に入ります
仕事は道徳でもありますよ
仕事が道徳でもあります
仕事をする運命の業の生まれなので
その義務を果たさないことは悪行為
非道徳です 我々は業で生まれたんです
この業は仕事をしろと言ってるんです
ただであげませんよ 人間に生まれたんだから
あの動物もやっぱり なんであの業で生まれ生活できるのは地獄だけ書いたの
餓鬼道もちょっと曖昧なんです
餓鬼道の中でも仕事をする羽目になる場合もあります
で 動物は仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
ただで食べられません
で 動物には何もできないんだけど
人間も仕事をしないと食べられません
だから仕事をする業で生まれたんです
それだったら仕事をしないっていうことは法則違反ですよ
悪行為です 非道徳です
仕事をしないつもりの人も
結局は不幸に陥る仕事をしているんです
仕事をしないでいられません
ですから 仕事をしない
しないと言ってはいけません
選んで選んで良い仕事をした方がいいんです
それは道徳です 自分と他人の役に立つ行為
幸福になる行為 善行為
善職業 善仕事です いわゆる自分の役に立つ
他人の役に立つ仕事をする
幸福になる それは善行為です
善職業です 善職業 聖なる職業なんです
あの聖職 聖職という単語があるでしょ
あの宗教家の仕事は聖職の人
悪いことばっかりしかやってないんですけど
あの 誰の仕事でも結局はよく考えると聖職なんです
善仕事をするということで
えっと 生命の役に立ち立たない
人間の世間役に立ちたい
人間の世界の国の社会の役に立ちたい
家族と仲間の家族の役に立ちたい
家族の役に立ちたい 最低他人に迷惑をかけないで
自分の力で生きていきたいという希望あるでしょうね
これはあの順番高い順番からどんどん効果順で書いたんです
で 生命の役に立ちたいといえば
規模がすごい高いんでしょ？人間の役に立ちでも
もうちょこっと次元が低い
世界の国の役に 世界の役に立ちたい
国の役に立ちたいけど
まだまだ小さくなってくるんですね
社会の役に立ちたいのは最も小さくなるわけですね
家族と仲間に役に立ちたい
もっと小さくなる 家族だけ幸せにしたいと思ったら
もったいない 小さくなる
最低私だけでもみんなに迷惑をかけないで生きてみますよと思ったら
まあ気持ちはものすごい小さくは希望はなくなるんです
という道徳的な目的を立てて人は生きるべきです
あの目的は巨大でなくてもいいんですよ
私が言うのは 巨大な目的から小さな目的まで
どちらでもいいんです
自分の範囲 好きな範囲で
その目的を立てて生きるべきなんです
最低自分だけでも 人に迷惑をかけないで生きてみますと
そういうのは善行為であって道徳です
慈しみの実践は最適な訓練です
とか言ったらのはちょっとわからなくなるんですけど
慈しみを訓練するとこれができるようになるんです
この目的を何か作るんですよ
あの効果順で書いてましたけど
皆様は 自分にできる順を決めてください
自分にできる順を決めて
あ 私はこの位置やと それからどう実行すればいいかと慈しみ込んでする
そうすると実行できるんです
だから 仕事をすることは道徳です
次に 親に甘える問題は考えてみます
えーと 親っていうのは尊敬するものでしょ
甘えるんじゃないんですよ
しかし 精神的に甘えても構わないんです
親には精神的に甘えていいんですよ
ちょっと可愛がってもらうとかね
ちょっと怒鳴られてもらうとかね
ちょこちょこと親に馬鹿にされてもらうとかね
そういうふうに まあ親にちょっと構ってもらうことは構わないんですよ
なぜならば認めてくれるし
ストレスもなくなる 親と一緒にいるとストレスはたまらないんです
不思議です 経済的に依存すること
甘えることは非道徳です
しかし 親の金に依存することというのは非道徳です
親を経済的に支えてあげるのは自分の義務だから
この義務を果たさないで逆さまにやってはいけないんです
親の話はそこら辺にします
これはいい で それで全部語ってますよ
親に甘えるっていうことはとんでもないことなんです
しかし 甘える方法はありますよ
親にも ただ可愛がってもらう
年取っても自分が 親はなんかもういろいろ自分の弱みを言ったり
恥をさらし出したりすると
そのものの見事にそれを聞いてくれるんですよ
いくら自分が恥をさらすことを失敗したことを言ったっても
親はちゃんと認めてくれるんです
まあまあ そんなことでお前はね
いつだって一人前になるのかとか
もう怒られたりとか あれでストレスは全部消えるんですよ
それは親から自分がもらう権利があるんですけど
お父さん車買いたいんだけど
200万ちょうだいでとんでもないことなの
それは逆なんです 親にしてあげなくちゃいけないんです
それだけまた繰り返したって意味がないんです
次に 技術能力 欲の関係
仕事で収入を得て生計を立てるのは人間の権利であり
義務でもあります 収入を得ることは皆様の権利なんです
それから義務でもあります
金を儲けないといけないんですよ
それは義務なんです 人間としての義務を義務だと思い
学んだり習ったりして
収入のある仕事にするのは欲であってはならないのです
そんなのは欲だったら何やってるんですかね
これ 義務ですよ 仕事をすること
それで給料をもらうこと
あるいは商売すること
それで商売でいくらか利益を作ること
これは権利であって 人間に生まれたんだから
同時に自分がやらなくちゃいけない義務でもありますよ
なんでそれ忘れてますかね？みんな欲でやってます
ラーメン屋さん作っちゃうと
これでなんとか儲かるぞとか
まあなんと頑張って でも月々 100万円取ってやるぞとか
これで悪行になっちゃうんです
散髪屋さんであろうが
歯医者さんであろうか
ラーメン屋さんであろうか
もうこれは必要でしょうに
だから彼らが必要なことをやってますから
彼らには収入をいただく義務が
権利があるんです それになんで欲が絡むんですかね
なんで商売に欲が絡むんですかね
皆様 仕事をする会社なんかでも欲ばっかしでしょうね
これはちょっと道が外れています
儲かりたい 金持ちになりたい
外車に乗りたいなどの汚れた思考では
成功するより失敗する割合が高いんです
だから世の中はそうなってます
仏教的にやればみんな 100%成功します
金も儲かっているし 罪も犯してないしということになるんです
商売も繁盛しているし
罪も犯してないという
これはブッダの教えの教えなんです
はい 出家は仕事をしないのかという
皆様にあまり興味ないかもしれませんね
その問題も日本の社会にあったんです
で 布施で生計を立てているから
経済活動 仕事をなどはしないという批判があります
よくこの学者さんたちが我々に貶したい時はよく使う言葉で
私はもう離れましたからね
まあ向こうは安全で何でも言えますけどね
今なんか言ったらまあ結構大変なことになると思いますけど
なんか嫌な日本ですね
我々は 日本の坊主はね
ちゃんと仕事をして 自分で家でもう作ってご飯作って食べてるんですけども
まあこのテーラワーダ仏教はね
まあみんな他人からね
食べてるだけだと だからＮＨＫのある番組でね
経済活動は全くしないんだと
だから間接的にこの対対国にかなり負担だと
お坊さんたちは言いたいんです
だからスリランカに対しても
外国いろんな新聞でむちゃくちゃ悪く言っても
全部お坊さんたちの悪く言ってるんですよ
我々のせいだと あの今戦争を受けているのは
どこまで嘘を言うのか
人を怒鳴ることもしない人々に
あそこまで人殺し言うならば
殺した時一つでも出してほしい
はい そういう批判があるんですよ
しかし 仕事をしないのは法則違反で罪なのです
仕事をしないということはありえないんです
汚れたままの心で修行もしないで
布施で布施のご飯を食べることは
あの仏教は用語あります
盗食 盗食だと説かれています
あれ これ日本語でないんですよ
盗食という単語は あのテーヤパリボーガっていう
翔太さん テーヤパリボーガは日本語でどう訳すればいいんですかね
盗みと 何でしょうね 財産ですよね
パリボーガっていうのはね
自業自得  自業ですか  うん
だからまあ一応盗食です
で 盗んで食べてるという
あの食は これお坊さんのことだから
食ってこの漢字が書いてあって
あるいは職業の職書いたっても同じ意味になるんです
お坊さんの場合はほとんどもう食べることで終わりますからね
必要なものを食べるもの
食べ物があれば十分ということだから
実はこの食ではなくて
仕事の職なんです 当職と言ってますから
仕事をするんですよ 他人の役に立つ生き方は仕事です
だから出家の生き方っていうのは
もう初めから他人の役に立つという
別に見返りも何もなく
もうそれが出家ですから
人の役に立つ生き方は出家ですから
もうそれその時点で仕事なんです
生活支援を受ける時 また現代問題です
あの給付金などは簡単に受けるものではありません
もらうだけは危険です
しかし 生活支援を受けなくてはならない人もたくさんいます
困っている人を助けなくてはならないということもあります
しかし いただくものは何でしたっけ？資金になるべきです
でなきゃもう危ないんです
例えば仕事がなくても
もう 3ヶ月間ももうなんとか
そうすると 3ヶ月間生活保護を受けたりしても構いませんよ
そこが資金なんです その生活保護金でご飯食べてなんとかしてずーっと頑張ってみるんだ
仕事見つかるまでは だから資金もらうのは構いませんよ
で 寄付金がどんな資金になるかちょっとわかりませんだけどね
ただでもらうんじゃないんで
それはとても良くないことです
はい そのポイントはそれで終わります
次 ホームレス 社会の また個人の経済活動は貪瞋痴で行っている証拠ですよ
それは 貪瞋痴で生きてみると
あの財布に穴ばっかしでしょうに
あの巨大な財布に ギッサギッサ切られているんです
その証拠はホームレスがいるんです
住居も五の管轄なので
基本的な権利なんですよ
これ 五に入ってますよ
皆様はコンピューターを買うと WINDOWS 入ってるだけではなくて
エクスプローラーまで入ってるでしょ？それからメディアプレーヤーまで入ってるでしょ？ CD でも聞くならば
DVD で見るならばとか
一応全部セットで入ってます
そこでこちらで生まれる場合は
食べるものとか この 4つのものは五のセットに入ってます
パックに パックに入ってるのに
ホームレスって何ですかね
住居入ってます え 食住薬だから
これは誰にでも恵まれてるはずなんですよ
面白いことは お金もなく
すごい苦しんでる 国々いたら子供たちとかいるでしょ
で 暴記になったらもうどうしようもないでしょ
でも人間がものすごくいつ立ってもいられなくて
さーっと行って助けちゃうんです
結局はあの子供たちはもうもうどんな苦しんで生まれたっても
ちゃんと 4つはついてくるんです
裸ではいないんです もうどうしても
もうだって服ぐちゃぐちゃボロボロ
なんか誰かがはい これ使ってくださいとあげたりするんです
これはもう業が働くんですよ
もらう側の業が だからこの私にとってみたら
すごいホームレスの現象は人の愚かさを示す異常現象です
それは たとえ少なくとも自分の収入を管理して使うことは個人の責任であり
理性的な生き方にもなるんです
最近 たくさんのホームレスの若者が出たでしょ
契約切れたところで自分の責任です
貪瞋痴で生きていたんだから
何年間も仕事をしたんだから
この現実を理解して契約したらいいんだよと
だからもう退職するまで仕事できるわけじゃないんだと覚えておくとね
ちょこちょこと貯まっておかなきゃいけないでしょうに
だからホームレスというのは異常現象であってはならないことです
あること自体異常なんですよ
インドやらこの暑い国々ではもう別にどうでも木の下でも寝ますけど
そこはもうそこでもう間に合ってます
業は楽なんです 自分の国ではあまり外に出ませんだけど
まあインドならまあダーンともう外に寝てどうったことはないと
だから寝る場所ぐらいはね
あのパックに入ってます
落ちてますね パックが壊れて
はい それで結論になります
あの この今までの話のね
あの適職を探して時間を無駄にしない
恵まれた仕事に慣れる
腕を磨けばそれが適職です
一人一人に必ず仕事があるのだとを認めて明るくなる
必ず仕事あるんです 明るく自信がある気持ちで仕事を明るくて自信がある気持ちで仕事を探すんです
暗い気持ちで仕事を探すんじゃないんです
仕事あるんですからね
ちょっと探さなくちゃ
見つかるまで 生かされてくれるのでは
で 自分の力で生きる あ
ちょっと間違った 生かされてくれないの
生かされてくれません
自分で生きる  疲れました
職業と仕事は必ず同一ではありません
失業があっても仕事なしではありえません
仕事はありますね それは説明しました
仕事は他の役に立つならば
職業がなくてもそれで生計を立てられる
生きてられる あの本当に職業職業じゃないんだけど
自分が役に立つ生き方してみれば
それでも十分です それで生きていられるんです
だから必ずしも職業なくてもちゃんと生きていられます
人に役に立てば 貪瞋痴の感情で生きるのではなく
慈しみの気持ちで生活をするということで終わります